hey guys it's Jan here the latest movie
of course on the big screen as Disney's
newest animated features who tropi list
which depending on where you live is
also called Zootopia the film follows
what happens when a scam artist Fox and
a hard-working rabbit who's a rookie cop
joined together to crack a mysterious
case of missing mammals basically it's a
mix of buddy cop movie Odd Couple comedy
and classic whodunit with shades of film
Noirs like Chinatown the voice cast is
superb and features the likes of Lucis
Idris Elba as Buffalo cop chief BOGO and
whip Flash's JK Simmons as Merline heart
and I love the teaming of a once upon a
time star Jennifer Goodwin as the
optimistic rabbit Judy Hopps and
Arrested Development's Jason Bateman as
a laid-back hustling Fox Nick Wilde they
play really nicely off each other and
make a superb comic duo pop star Shakira
also gets a cameo as a pop star called
gazelle that performs a new upbeat and
super earworm a song called try
everything written by SIA and star gates
speaking of music the film score was
composed by Michael chiquinho and as
you'd expect it perfectly fits the
movies tone throughout right down to its
Hitchcock and the Godfather inspired
moments in case you're interested it's
actually Joe quino's first score for a
feature-length animated Disney movie
though of course he's done plenty of
brilliant work with Pixar including
inside out in The Incredibles and a
Director's Byron Howard who gave us
tangled rich Moore who gave us wreck-it
Ralph and Jarrod Bush who's directing
for the first time and also co-wrote the
script with wreck-it Ralph writer Phil
Johnston have done a great job bringing
to life the beautifully detailed city of
zootropolis and Disney's animators
deserve handfuls of high-fives all round
for creating such a beautifully
colourful and incredibly well
thought-out world which is cleverly
divided into different districts based
on climates and species for example the
Sahara Square for desert animals tundra
town for polar bears and moose and for
rodents little rodentia which is the
location of an ingenious chase scene the
story of self feels particularly apt and
well-timed dealing as it does with
prejudice and inclusivity using
different species are specifically the
idea of predators and prey than
interesting way into those issues
playing both with and against people's
preconceived notions of different
animals from shrews to sloths and
elephants to cheetahs the film mainly
manages to avoid being preached
it only feels a touch on the nose at
times the movies also full of knowing
humor including jokes about Disney's own
movies and you'll also see in here tons
of pop-culture references and some
brilliantly funny Easter eggs two
well-known films and TV shows in fact
I've made a video with all those Easter
eggs and references and I'll put a link
here as soon as it's live so to sum up
so you trop Ellis is a charming Odd
Couple comedy which blends a gorgeously
realized world superb voice cast timely
message and elements from classic films
and pop culture to create a movie that
has plenty to keep both adults and kids
entertained it's around an hour 50
minutes the movie feels a touch on the
long side but I did still very much
enjoy my time visiting the city of Zee
tropi 'less zootropolis gets 4 out of 5
flicks now tell me what you're looking
forward to about zootropolis and if
you've seen it already what did you
think and who are your favourite Disney
characters and why let me know in the
comments below as well as my zootropolis
Easter egg video I'll also have a video
up soon with fun facts about zootropolis
and I'll add annotations here once
they're ready to watch if you like this
review I really appreciate you sharing
it and do feel free to subscribe I've
got loads more videos on Disney Pixar
and other animated movies thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
you